Morticia and Gomez are one of the
spookiest couples in pop culture history
so why are fans up in arms about their
portrayal in Wednesday Tim Burton's
Wednesday has finally arrived on Netflix
and in a snap or two for the fans out
there it has been snatched up by eager
audiences who have binged through this
new take on The Addams Family's
dark-minded daughter in particular fans
have praised Jenna Ortega's performance
as Wednesday Adams in the new series
Wednesday takes Center Stage after being
enrolled in Nevermore Academy where she
begins investigating a series of brutal
murders obviously it wasn't exactly what
you'd call a shocking Revelation to see
Wednesday getting the most attention out
of The Addams Family we know love and
fear the show is named after her after
all still would it really be an Adam's
adjacent project if the other members of
the titular family didn't make an
appearance for some though therein lies
the problem now that viewers have
finished with the first season of
Wednesday it seems that summer taking
issue with the heads of The Adams Family
household I've always been open to
constructive criticism in the show
Morticia and Gomez are played made by
Catherine Zeta Jones and Louis Guzman
who while having nowhere near as much
screen time as Ortega still had some
serious shoes to fill the roles have
been irrevocably bound to Angelica
Houston and Raul Julia since they
brought the characters to the big screen
with flawless chemistry and Berry
sonenfield's 1991 filmed The Addams
Family and its 1993 sequel Adams Family
Values
I would die for her
I would kill for her
either way what Bliss it may be that
these Rock Solid performances still
linger in the minds of fans since some
viewers have claimed that they failed to
see even a flicker of a spark between
Morticia and Gomez in this new take on
the characters if you're familiar with
cartoonist Charles Adams original
characters you'll know that Morticia and
Gomez Adams more than look the part on
Wednesday with Guzman's short stature
providing a humorous contrast to Zeta
Jones's height however looks aren't
everything and some fans seem to feel
that romance is very much dead between
the two which is unfortunate since the
Raul Julia and Angelica Houston
incarnations of the characters are
depicted as such lovebirds in the
television subreddit one fan expressed
their concern about the characters
casting they wrote absolutely not sold
on the casting for Morticia and Gomez
though didn't mind it at all when I
first watched the trailer but felt like
they had zero chemistry on the show
another redditor agreed saying Catherine
Zeta Jones was definitely miscast in my
opinion but you're right about their
chemistry being off as Gomez and
Morticia as the wild than seductive
couple they're supposed to be but if the
final choices weren't up to Snuff or
audiences who else would fit the bill
for one of Pop culture's maddest couples
one Reddit user suggests ideally I would
have cast Oscar Isaac and Ava Green
Oscar is a fan of the character and
voice acted the role in the 2019
animated Addams Family movie still if a
second season of Wednesday gets the
green light Zeta Jones and Luis Guzman
might get another shot to capture the
passion that some believe has been
missing this time around everyone is
allowed to have one bad day after all